perfection equals paralysis
perfectionism doesn't advance anything
ironically it's okay not to have to be
perfect all the time
what's that believe nation it's Evan I
believe in you and this channel is
designed to be a part of your daily
success routine so today let's learn one
of the most common rules that successful
people follow don't chase perfection
also if you want to know a grant cardone
tell mil you myself and others have to
say about building unstoppable
confidence check out my 250 for
confidence series where every day for
the next 254 days I will send you a
morning video for free to help you build
your confidence the link to join is in
the description below you have to go
build self-confidence there's a gap
between who people are and what they
tell you they want to accomplish if
you're doing work that you love you're
more likely to follow through you're
more likely to do it because it doesn't
feel like work because you love doing it
[Music]
perfection equals paralysis
okay so debt you you can never make a
perfect to say no no if you left at the
engineers no car would ever come off the
assembly line no car would ever come off
the assembly line and I've been in
business with enough engineers I can
tell attest to that with my hand on my
heart they'd still be trying to trying
to make it better and the internet
business is very much the same the
Internet kids want to test and test and
test and they would want the the landing
page to be this and roll it out the
great thing about the Internet is your
results are instantaneous and you can
make changes instinct correct I mean if
something that I'm over seen at the
Concord level 60,000 feet doesn't work
in two days can it forget about it and
move on and today at our meeting now the
young kids are we ran a three days
sir and we closed it down and they are
thinking I'm gonna ask why I said no
that's fine next because without them
making mistakes and without them being
allowed to make the decision they never
get any better and in 95 percent of the
time I know probably better than they do
but we're never going you know we're
never going to be able to know
everything or have them know everything
unless and they will never know
everything but unless they makes
mistakes and make mistakes and get
comfortable with making mistakes
perfectionism what emerge for me in the
data was that perfectionism is not about
striving for excellence or healthy
striving which yeah I'm for yeah it's a
cognitive behavioral process a way of
thinking and feeling that says this if I
look perfect do it perfect work perfect
and live perfect I can avoid or minimize
shame blame and judge haha you know what
I thought when I was reading this I had
another aha
AHA to people this was my other aha that
perfectionism I never gotten this before
tolerate this that perfectionism is the
ultimate fear that the people who are
walking
as perfectionist who have to have
everything so yeah that they are
ultimately afraid that the world is
going to see them for who they really
are and they won't measure up there's no
question that's that's what it that's
correct
right that's exactly what it is okay
it's fear because it's very different
than trying to be excellent and hard and
doing your best yeah yeah and so I call
perfectionism the 20-ton shield we
carried around thinking it's gonna
protect us from being hurt yeah but it
protects us from being seen commit to
getting more done the more you get done
the more you will earn period in the
story why do I get more done because I
post I post without looking at it I
simply get more done why because I'm
committed to getting more done I'm not
I'm not committed to doing it perfectly
these guys all work with me I wish you
could see our studio okay but I got
Francisco here I got Johnny I got Nathan
here I got guys guys do I ever talk
about doing anything perfectly have I
ever said anything about doing something
perfectly I do it I just do I just do a
lot of stuff okay I'm like put that
stuff on the wall there you go that's
good okay look man Johnny's doing the
whole room that's that that's Natalie
there's Nathan okay we got a good group
here right so check it out number one
you got to commit number two you got to
do whatever is in front of you just do
it it doesn't need to be approved it
doesn't need to be checked we're not
hunting like I'm not deer hunting here
I'm not taxi driver and the deer hunter
you know we're we're not like I'm not
going public here I'm not trying to
raise a billion dollars I'm just trying
to get my damn job done it's an
Instagram post man oh let me check it oh
let me do a filter oh let me change it
let me change the right so many people
are obsessed with becoming perfect that
they never take action and they never
learn to enjoy this moment that may be
one of the greatest tragedies any of us
can face that right now whatever we are
however we are however good
we are whatever we've accomplished that
we fail to enjoy this moment because we
have a judgement about who we are deep
down because we haven't acted in a way
that's perfect and I get it we have this
drive it's innate unless we want to be
great it's one of the five primary human
drivers to pursue mastery to want to
master something and truly be
extraordinary I understand the drive but
don't let it corrode you don't ever do
something that eats you alive from the
inside you've got to have a vision of
yourself that allows you to morph and
change and learn from your mistakes but
if you value perfection over learning
then you're never going to become the
person that you'd be capable of becoming
and as Anna Quindlen said the thing that
is really hard and really amazing is
giving up on being perfect and beginning
the work of becoming yourself there is
no perfect first step there is no
perfect plan there is no perfect time to
get started a lot of people are so held
up on finally what the perfect first
thing is to do that they do nothing and
that's the ultimate failure the ultimate
failure is doing nothing and just
sitting on this idea and never taking
any kind of action for it because you're
worried about making misstep you're
worried about making mistake you're
worried that it's not perfect
your perfectionism is killing you it's
preventing you from doing amazing things
in your life and with the business you
take any step you have a vision here's
what I want to accomplish here's my goal
I want to write a book I want to start a
company I want to whatever it is
whatever first step comes to my goal and
do that and then adjust adjust adjust
adjust you can have the best plan in the
world right and I'm all for business
planning it's not just I'm just gonna
throw an idea out there and see what
happens right you can plan you can model
success you can look at what has worked
for people but you have to go out and do
it because the best plan is obsolete as
soon as you start executing on it and
this is what almost killed my first
business this is how I've learned the
lesson because I was that guy I was too
perfectionist I didn't want to do
anything so I had it all figured out and
you only later realize
what you think you figured out you have
no idea what you're talking about
because you haven't gone out and done
anything yet
I lost a 40 million dollar deal in my
first company I was making $300 a month
sucking in my company turned it around
started making an income and had an
opportunity to sell my business for 40
million dollars I lost it to my biggest
competitor because I had to have the
perfect plan because I spent an entire
summer working on the perfect plan and I
was too late to the table I was looking
the wrong way
what made great sense on paper wasn't
actually what was gonna happen in the
market and I lost a 40 million dollar
deal because of it that kills that sucks
I was 22 years old it's important to
plan what you need to do and don't get
so hung up on having the perfect step
don't worry what the first step is
people write in and say what's my first
it doesn't matter something do something
and then do something again tomorrow and
do something again the next day and
every day you get a little bit better
start taking massive action that's how
you're gonna get that idea out of your
head
finally and out into the world's you can
start reaping the benefits and having a
big impact on this world like you are
meant to do perfectionism doesn't
advance anything ironically as a
creative and as a designer there's no
wrong way to go about the future of your
career the only the only failure is not
to try you know and I think that
designers we all have like a creators or
artists we have a natural convention to
sort of be maybe tormented or a little
bit of like an inner struggle is is the
work living up to its fullest potential
or is it you know is it as great as the
work that you oughta lies from your your
design idols but at the end of the day
it's your body of work and it's the
amount of work and the refinement of
that work that will define who you are
as a creative I think it's probably more
of a self-imposed rule
that growing up I always felt that I
almost had to keep it together all the
time to keep a composure all the time to
have all my ducks in a line all the time
and as an actor again like with the note
that Warren had given me about letting
go you just sometimes are naturally not
gonna be in control all the time and I
think once I realized that that was a
rule that I was putting on myself and
that I could just discard the world like
opens up all of a sudden these more
spontaneous magical moments can happen
whether that's in your daily life
whether that's at your job I mean even
if when in your relationship with
yourself it's something so important to
know that it's okay not to have to be
perfect all the time one of the patents
that I'm noticing here Eric in in a lot
of consistent ways with new
entrepreneurs is that they're covering
up their lack of ability to handle
uncertainty by doing research under the
guise of chasing perfectionism yeah all
right that's like saying listen I'm
gonna read all the books on darts that I
can read so that my first dart is gonna
be a bull's-eye yeah that doesn't work
get up stand up to the plate yeah or the
akhi throw the dart and the first one
may miss the board but then you adjust
you throw the second one it gets a
little closer you throw the third one it
gets a little closer now eventually
you're going to be getting bull's-eyes
because you've used to throwing not used
to reading books on darts you experience
yeah it's pretty nice thinking they're
better than this one yeah see if I am
trying to be perfect then to all you
perfectionist people out there listen to
me yeah again another one of my men so
I've spent on many years with Tony
Robbins right will tell you perfection
is the lowest standard and the reason
it's the lowest standard is because it's
unattainable so what you're trying to be
perfect by being perfect you guarantee
you never will be
you're the most people try to be perfect
you know try to do this most people are
afraid of being imperfect I think this
is go to the broadcasting nation problem
they procrastinate or under the guise of
research oh yeah all I just yeah I'll
just you know do two more focus groups
all just like you know us do another
hours surfing to see if there's any
other your ideas I can benchmark no shut
up do your research
yeah limit it get in
swing the bat then reassess but at least
you in the game you can't be perfect
don't try to be perfect it's impossible
no one is perfect if you make a mistake
you have to live with it and you have to
be able to to grow from it
you can't continue to make mistake after
mistake after mistake and then think
that you're gonna be able to come back
from that when I approached magic I just
showed up I did a lot of preparation all
I have to do is be ready I guess and
that I try to apply it through my life
no no I just have to get ready you know
I just have to do what is asked of me
and and do as much as I can without
driving myself insane because I there's
a negative side of perfectionism in my
nature anyway I can only speak for
myself there's a negative flaw and
there's a very dangerous trap and I
think one of the biggest killers is ego
and when it's the negative side of
perfectionism when one starts playing
God you know and I mean literally there
is a killer there is a lethal part of
one's own ego
now I've got a really special bonus clip
with Jessie J on how it's important to
not try to be perfect but before that
it's time for the three-point landing
questions time to move from just
watching another video to actually
taking action in your life or your
business and if you're feeling bold
leave your replies in the comments below
here we go
question number one how is chasing
perfection paralyzing you number two
what's the cost to you if you don't
change your thinking and number three
what will you do today to just start
I would never surround myself with
people that tell me I'm perfect because
I'm not and I don't want to be 23
sometimes I sing out of tune and
sometimes I lose weight and I want a
game way sometimes I say stuff that
shouldn't and sometimes I'm gonna make
mistakes but life would be boring if you
lived it like it's gonna be really in
the paper and you don't want it to be so
I know then I said yes he was out to me
it was pitchy but I've never mind and
I'm proud of that raise your standard
Apple at the core its core value is that
that people need passion and not one
drop of my self-worth depends on your
acceptance man if you want to know what
is stopping you from having success I
highly recommend the video right there
next to me I think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there dr. Wayne Dyer houses as the
famous phrase where it's not oh I'll
believe it when I see it it's like I'll
see it when I believe it